il la république en marge du val d'oise
a fait parler de lui grâce à cette
intervention samedi sur france 5 écoutez
le vous posez cette question pour d une
jeune fille de 2 ans qui porterait le
voile est donc très élevé dans une
famille musulmane est ce que vous me
poseriez la question sur une famille
catholique à une jeune fille à qui on
met un serre-tête autres bien sûr que
non alors évidemment depuis il s'est
excusé c'était ce matin sur public sénat
j'ai eu cette comparaison malheureuse il
faut bien le dire entre le voile
islamique et un serre tête puisque
évidemment le serre tête et pas un
accessoire religieux il faut dire
qu'évidemment entre-temps marlène
schiappa l'avait totalement désavouée
c'était au grand jury rtl lci le figaro
moi je crois que tout ne se vaut pas je
pense qu'il faut cesser cette forme de
relativisme qui nous fait mettre sur le
même plan des choses qui sont très
opposées aucune femme dans le monde ne
sera lapidé par ce qu'elle a refusé de
porter un serre-tête un serre tête ce
n'est pas un symbole pour briser
complètement de lens marchand taillade
vous êtes plutôt surligne tâche et sur
la ligne elle a eu aussi une ligne un
peu fluctuante au cours des années donc
je pourrais pas m'associer à marlène
schiappa clairement sur cette question
là et d'ailleurs sa dernière tribune sur
décathlon est assez alambiquée
suffisamment la mickey pour pas savoir
ce qu'elle pense
en l'occurrence euréliens tâche et je
connais très bien sa circonscription la
conscription puisque c'est la seule
circonscription où a lieu en 2015 le
salon de la femme musulmane de pontoise
où j'étais personnellement présente
manifestant contre la présence
d'islamistes radicaux et en l'occurrence
est une circonscription où l'islamisme
fait rage où il ya eu des négociations
électorales au moment des législatives
déjà en 2007 sur la base de la
construction d'une mosquée qui a été
ensuite mise aux mains de salafistes
c'est un endroit où on a accepté
d'enterrer la 10e circonscription on a
enterré dans le cimetière communal
la dépouille d'un terroriste qui s'était
attaqué à saint-etienne du rouvray à un
curé c'est une circonscription que vous
laissez entendre c'est qu'il fait de
l'électoralisme électorale il a été
qu'elle ya quelques mois inaugurer une
mosquée à jouy-le-moutier
voilà donc aurélien taché
il joue l'électoralisme à mort il fait
partie de cette frange de la république
en marche qu'on peut qualifier d' islam
aux gauchos compatibles en tout cas
c'est quelqu'un qui clairement est
contre la laïcité ou en tout cas une
forme de la laïcité qui ne correspond
absolument pas ni à notre constitution
ni à la loi de 1905
il va falloir à un moment que la
république en marche et un dialogue sur
cette question alors un positionnement
et quel manuel macron arrête de nous
voyez on est mal remercie vous êtes vous
posé les bonnes questions au bon moment
parce que c'est exactement le coeur du
sujet pour le françois pas voulu qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire et ce que ce n'est
pas un problème que le parti du
président le parti majoritaire ne soit
pas au clair sur cette question j'ai
vraiment pas comment macron fait pour
supporter des gens aussi stupide excusez
moi intérieur de aurélien de monteils
disait tout ce qui est excessif est
insignifiant malheureusement c'est très
signifiants dans son cas ces gens là ils
ont été armés depuis très longtemps dans
une culture cathophobes tout ce qu'ils
savent faire c'est taper sur une église
catholique en déclin face à un islam qui
se radicalise
ils sont totalement désarmé ils sont
incapables de penser la situation on l'a
vu avec marlène schiappa et sa
déclaration hallucinante sur la
comparaison entre les islamistes et la
magnifique
ça montre aux murs oui mais à chaque
fois une sexy à chaque fois qu'il dise
une bêtise il s'excuse ça va être un
voilà en permanence c'est étonnant et ça
dit je comprends pas comment à la tête
de l'état on n'essaye pas de mettre de
l'ordre
parmi ces gens qui sont incapables
d'avoir une réflexion
ils appliquent leurs critères
cathophobes qui ont marché dans une
certaine mesure à l'époque des grands
combats
menés par la laïcité contre l'église
mais qui ne sont plus du tout approprié
aujourd'hui dans un pays où il n'y a
plus de conflits avec l'église
catholique
mais c'est un prisme culturel c'est dans
leur adn fergane azéri est ce que du
coup le principal problème c'est pas
macro lui-même qu'il n'a pas clarifié
pendant la campagne je sais pas si on
peut aller extrapolé jusque là mais moi
je pense que rien entaché va pas et
consomme reprenait un peu trop vite
il était pris dans le feu de la
discussion moi je devrais rappeler quand
même les propos qu'il avance y croyez
c'est à dire les lapsus ça existe
vraiment ce qui a commencé la discussion
disant moi je suis là paf à la loi je ne
fais pas la morale est donc
effectivement pour comment dire refuser
le fait d'interdire le voile islamique
il a pris une comparaison comme ça qu'il
n'est il a dit quelque chose de stupide
quand même dans sa maison était
construite du pin je suis pas je ne suis
pas certain qu'il était là pour ne pas
écrire qu'il n'était pas là pour
appliquer la loi
il ya 18 mois mais pas davantage c'est
que ces messieurs ce cas pareils doit en
tant que politicien à qui je fais
l'amour et en l'occurrence il ne donne
pas déjà je fais la loi je ne sais pas
la morale et moi je trouve cette
distinction très intéressante parce que
cette distinction voix et morale elle
nous interdit pas de critiquer le voile
islamique
elle nous interdit pas de critiquer de
penser que s'il s'agit d'adam symbole
rétrograde s'agit là d'un symbole d'une
idéologie autoritaire simplement c'est
aussi une manière d'expliquer expliqué
qu'il ya une division du travail une
division des tâches entre l'état qui se
doit d'être neutre vis-à-vis des
idéologies aussi rétrograde
puisse-t-elle être et la société civile
qui elle effectivement est légitime à
s'indigner qu'on puisse effectivement
voile est une petite fille aux qu'on
puisse comparer le voile islamique à des
symboles beaucoup plus anodin comme un
serre tête
donc je pense cette division du travail
là elle est intéressante à souligner est
malheureusement effectivement la
polémique a fait qu'on ne l'a pas
suffisamment entendue sur sur cet aspect
là de la polémique hervé nathan le
serre-tête alors c'est un signe
religieux
je me souviens d'une philosophe célèbre
très célèbre dans les années 60 qui
portait un serre tête comme ça cellier
de simone de beauvoir il portait son ca
mot serre tête et le quartier nord de
l'île et personne personne accusée
d'être une traque catholique donc dû
certainement registre forte histoire de
serre tête s'effectue moi je moi je suis
d'accord ces signifiants
ça me rappelle enfin tous ces
comparaisons
montre la confusion et l'absence
d'esprit politique parce que ce qui
manque là dedans
nancy aurait ni attaché mais aussi chez
marina ciapa mais aussi avec d'autres
c'est l'idée que quand on sait quand on
est face à ce phénomène en face à un
phénomène qui n'est pas politique or
pour moi c'est la politique c'est à dire
qu'en fait nous sommes face à des
organisations qui viennent qui sont en
france qui vivent qui se sont en france
et qui font de la politique et qui
réclament un statut politique différent
pour une partie de la population c'est
ça le but des salafistes en france je
laisse de côté même du terroriste parce
que c'est encore ça c'est encore une
nuance de gris comme on dit mais les
mouvements salafistes et mouvements qui
sont nées des frères musulmans sont
l'art en france et il exige d'avoir un
privilège au sens strict du terme une
loi privée ils disent nous sommes
musulmans donc puisque nous sommes
musulmans nous avons droit de 2,2 nous
avons droit dans les cantines nous avons
le droit de mettre un voile sur la tête
de nos femmes et de nos filles nous
avons le droit d'avoir de refuser un
certain nombre d'enseignements dans
l'enseignement gêné d'en haut dans les
lycées etc
c'est ça les bus politiques auxquels
nous sommes confrontés sont confrontés
les républicains gipa la république ça
veut rien dire à un public et la
république c'est tout le monde
non les républicains c'est à dire les
muséums les citoyens que nous sommes
tes dires en tant que personnage
politique engagée nous sommes confrontés
à des forces politiques qui veulent
imposer au sein de notre république des
lois privées ça c'est du but politique
et quand on est là à se poser la
question est ce que c'est la morale ou
est ce que c'est la loi
eh bien on racle le but le but c'est de
combat excusez moi le but c'est de
combattre et de refouler leurs foulées
politiquement oui ma mère louise et
d'analysé au final je pense qu'il n'y a
pas de solution dans les changements de
la loi par exemple je pense qu'il n'y a
de solution que dans la mobilisation
politique des citoyens qui ceux qui
doivent se lever s'opposer manifester et
dire que leur refus de ça voilà on ne
s'en sortira que comme ça ça métrage où
les années voire des décennies
mais ce combat là c'est le combat que
nous devons mener il n'y a pas d'autre
solution
sinon on va commencer à voir on va on va
on va toujours se pose est juste car dès
la parole ces catholiques et ses
quelques fins et des armées de
les avis des internautes vous êtes très
nombreux sur le figaro.fr à intervenir
monsieur babineau qui dit hystérisation
autour de l'islam dans le débat nicole
qui dit aurélien tâche et qui prend la
parole veut imposer sa vision de
l'immigration et de l'islam et nous
avons posé la question selon vous donc
les députés la république en marche
doivent qu'ils suivent la ligne
d'aurélien attaché ou de marlène
schiappa sur la laïcité
et là c'est très clairement à 62% pour
marlène schiappa françois pauly aucune
explication du débat il ya simplement un
constat il ya quelques années j'ai fait
un débat avec tariq ramadan qui m'a dit
la loi sur la burqa ne sera jamais
appliqué en france parce que d'abord
vous ne pouvez pas l'appliquer vous
allez provoquer des émeutes
et de toute façon sion l'appliquent sur
les champs-elysées ça fera partir les
femmes dès qu'ils viennent des pays du
golfe et qui consomme quand vous avez vu
que redouane faid il a été arrêté il
avait une burqa sur la tête pourquoi
parce qu'il savait qu'ils seraient pas
interpellé
donc il ya aucune hystérisation et un
recul de la loi républicaine
pour rappel on a quand même un premier
ministre edouard philippe maire qui
était maire du havre le havre il y a
deux ans donc avant qu'il soit nommé 7
septembre 2002 2016
avant donc 2017 avant qu'elle doit
philippe de vienne en tout cas premier
sa dette 2016 et bien il y a eu la venue
d'annie ramadan qui est organisée par
une association célèbre le havre du
savoir association salafistes hani
ramadan donc j'ai personnellement
prévenu la mairie du havre donc edouard
philippe edouard philippe n'a pas réagi
trois semaines plus tard il y avait une
réunion équivalente à celle de juillet
puisque organisée par l'antenne locale
de juillet qui je le rappelle est proche
des frères musulmans et doivent philippe
n'a rien fait donc on a aussi un premier
ministre qui est dans la lâcheté la plus
totale face à l'islam radical et qui je
le rappelle est un proche de 2
alain juppé et alain juppé avaient les
mêmes pratiques aussi à bordeaux il a
reçu tariq ramadan en grande pompe
donc tout ça ne laisse rien présager de
très très bons vous dites quoi il ya un
silence complice qui il est ce qu'un
silence consiste parce que quand on est
un élu quand on est un politique et
qu'on n'agit pas dans ce genre de
situation c'est c'est pire qu'un silence
complice pour moi c'est c'est vraiment
laid c'est la gangrène s'installer et
finalement renoncer totalement au
renoncement en fait la galerie oui moi
je voudrais vous redire sur ce qu'il
disait en tailleur sur le fait que la
confusion entre des bâlois soit un débat
futile moi je ne pense pas justement le
problème de l'islam radical vient du
fait que cette mairie qui aspirent à
confondre normes sociales privées et
ordre public donc c'est bien l'idée même
de sécularisation du droit qui est
attaqué par cette idéologie et en ce
sens je pense pas que ce soit un débat
critique de rappeler effectivement cas
d'un côté la société civile qui est
légitime d'appliquer ces normes du
moment où là où elle renoncer victime de
l'impérialisme idéologiques religieux ou
culturel et le législateur je voulais
juste rappeler c'est qu'en fait on n'est
pas devant une question religieuse et
une certaine manière fait même elle est
le comble la question qui nous est posée
est pas une question de la place de la
religion dans la société la question
c'est comment on combat une idéologie
qui veut imposer des règles différentes
en fonction de poids des normes et
dialogues et de l'ouïe des normes des
normes y compris normes juridiques
différentes en fonction popul des
populations différentes voilà
et ça c'est celle qu'elle recèle un
combat politique et ghana question parce
que aurélien tâche et n'a pas répondu à
la question du voile en l'occurrence
quand on parle d'une gamine de 11 ou 12
ans parle bien d'un enfant et on parle
de maltraitance parce que une enfant il
ya des études médicales qui démontre une
enfant qui porte le voile
trop jeune c'est une gamine qui aura des
problèmes psychosomatiques et c'est une
gamine qui va être en carence de
vitamine d
donc en réalité il ya maltais
maltraitance de l'enfant et refuser de
regarder sans face alors que le
gouvernement est parfaitement courant de
cette étude c'est aussi un vrai problème
on va attendre de voir ce que le bureau
exécutif de la république en marche qui
se réunit ce soir
décidé et ce qu'ils décideront
clairement les choses ou pas je pense
que ça fera l'objet d'un prochain débat
abdelaziz bouteflika le président qui en
est à son cinquième mandat un quatrième
mandat écrit une lettre à ses
concitoyens pour annoncer la candidature
sa candidature à la prochaine
présidentielle
à 82 ans donc ils les prêts à entamer un
cinquième mandat
que doit faire la france peut-elle même
faire quelque chose bernard kouchner
était ce matin sur rmc écouter son point
de vue les plaies ne sont pas
complètement renfermé refermer du tout
entre l'algérie et la france d'un côté
comme de l'autre surtout du côté
algérien est ce que ça veut dire que la
france doit se taire mais non ça veut
dire que la france soit prudente et
qu'elle soit pas arrogante et j'ai ça
suffit et qu'elle considère que
l'algérie est chez comme ça est un pays
indépendant
hervé nathan c'est c'est fini le devoir
d'ingérence alors à part qu'on est bien
marginale bernard kouchner
quand on est plein meeting il faut aller
plus ministre
alors c'est vrai que la france ne dise
quel point sur le venezuela parce que
c'est à 9000 kilomètres mais elle ne
dirait pas ne dit rien de ce qui se
passe quasiment sans frontières c'est
une erreur il
il faudrait que la france il ya un
problème c'est que si on dit quelque
chose et qu'on semble pas si la france
dit quelque chose en faveur de quelqu'un
ou de quelques personnalités aux
quelques cons politique en algérie
c'est le meilleur moyen de le saborder
parce que la propagande est tellement
violente en algérie qu évidemment
l'appui de la france
effectivement il ya le conflit colonial
est encore présent au moins de l'autre
côté de la méditerranée s'est resserré
un arc tiens c'est un argument de
propagande peut-être d'ailleurs coup ça
va on va peut-être sa peur